hey guys justin here with a gamespot
news update it looks like we finally
have a release date for the previously
delayed PlayStation exclusive driveclub
originally planned as a launch title for
the PlayStation 4 the game was delayed
until early 2014 the latest trailer
though sets a launch date of October 8
2014 which is really closer to late 2014
but at least we have a specific date now
PlayStation president of worldwide
studios Shuhei Yoshida has released a
statement regarding the game we are
committed to delivering on our ambitious
promise of creating a truly innovative
and socially connected racing game the
problem with being ambitious is you have
to be prepared to accept there will be
challenges along the way driveclub lost
its director call rogers for undisclosed
reasons earlier this year and yoshida
also announced his replacement today
paul rushy rushed in ski Yoshida said to
look out for plenty more news on
driveclub in the coming weeks including
a blog update direct from Russia
tomorrow will have continuing news on
driveclub as it develops here on
gamespot com